the u.s. is expected to send a plane to
Japan to bring back the American
passengers from a cruise ship that was
quarantined due to the corona virus the
number of confirmed coronavirus cases is
now more than 49,000 worldwide including
15 cases here in the US the outbreak has
led to more than 1500 deaths in China
alone
Deborah pata is in Hong Kong with more
on the plan to evacuate the Americans
good morning we're learning that at
least 380 Americans and their families
will be evacuated from the diamond
princess I spoke to one of the
passengers who told me she received an
email from the American Embassy in Japan
offering her a seat on a US chartered
plane leaving tomorrow the diamonds
princess has been in Yokohama for well
over a week now the most common ailment
on board appears to be boredom
passengers have been confined to their
cabins with only the occasional stroll
allowed on the deck in Wuhan China where
the epidemic started social media
postings show ongoing draconian measures
by the Chinese government to contain the
virus the front door the family
suspected of being infected is welded
shut
emergency workers spray disinfectant
inside offices as workers just sit at
their computers and yellow body bags are
still being removed from homes and
hospitals outside of China the diamond
princess is the site of the biggest art
break with its over two hundred and
fiction's including more than a dozen
Americans on Sunday Americans on board
the ship wishing to be evacuated will be
taken by bus to a u.s. chartered plane
but before boarding they will undergo a
health screening symptomatic passengers
may not be allowed to fly for CBS this
morning Saturday I'm Debora patta
in Hong Kong
you